suit this is mental
power
am i like some sort of secret agent
it's a little more complicated than that
[Applause]
what were your initial reactions when
you found out that you will be in
marvel's moon night i cried i was like
what i had just finished watching all
the movies in order of story
and then i got the audition and booked
it and it really just felt unreal i'm
like is this real i and you know you
can't talk about it so
for so long i'm like
this is happening
i heard you got an insta dm
yeah muhammad yab's wife messaged me on
instagram and she's like my husband's
interested in you for this marvel
project and i contacted my manager and i
was like is this real and she was like i
don't know i'm like instagram like i
don't even go on instagram that much so
and you know people say things all the
time yeah
i don't know if i need to believe this i
kind of wish it was true and then it was
true that's true congratulations
um your character layla is a completely
new character right so how would you
describe her and her importance to oscar
isaac's uh mark or like steven's gym
yeah
she's a strong resilient woman who goes
after what she wants and she's also
vulnerable and and i can't speak to her
relationship with them but she's known
mark from her past and then she suddenly
meets steven
and is taken aback because she doesn't
know stephen
and she's um
i think that's all i'm really allowed to
say about her
okay that's fair but what about her made
you want to play her you know they
didn't tell me much about her in the
beginning but they said egyptian and
that was the key word i was like i'll do
it you're sold
yeah
speaking of it as an arab myself it is
so freaking nice to see you know
representation in hollywood
especially in a world as expansive and
celebrated as marble um so could you
share what it was like to be his
representation that many marvel fans
never really got to saw
yeah i um
i wish i had this growing up you know
seeing an arab woman like in a marvel
project on the scale that would have
been amazing and i it's it's an honor to
be able to play it and i hope that women
all over especially arab women but you
know women all over can feel like they
have a space and something at the scale
and can
it gives them a space to a freedom to
share their voice
as well
and also for people around the world to
see the middle east in a different way i
understand that there's like generally
one portrayal of the middle east it's
changing but there seems you know there
is a stereotype and i i really think
that we're ready to bring in that shift
how much of that shift was you know
impacted by like working with muhammad
like what was it like working with him
oh he's incredible and him and his wife
became instant family to me and he has
such a passion for how much he loves
egypt i don't know if anyone loves egypt
more than muhammad like he
wanted to portray it in such an
authentic way and for him he's like i
want to stop wars and i want to change
the world and i'm like cool let's do it
and so i love how he works and i love
how
true he likes to be and considerate all
over even if we just disagreed on
something he was still there to hear i
mean we both had that kind of
relationship where communication was
everything but um
it wouldn't be what it is without
muhammad
when it is far from like your typical
superhero you know obviously he has like
deep like
mental issues um but that presents
opportunities for storytelling to
paraphrase someone like how would you
describe someone who is like dressed up
in white and like jumping around town in
a white suit i mean how do you describe
someone like that he's like
he i don't even know someone who is he's
actually someone who's going through a
lot
you know
a deep internal struggle and is trying
to do the right thing and
um
his condition manifests in different
ways
and controls him in different ways you
know which you can look at like
conscious and everything
all those external forces um
[Music]
and the way he
is also stephen
just it it just shows
it's giving an idea of like a hyper
supernatural idea of
this condition
[Music]
you